thanks to the organizers for inviting me
so I wanted to talk about something
called moment matching polynomials and
this is joint work with ragu mecha and I
should say that one of the applications
of this work was independently
discovered by Daniel Caine
so I mentioned him and the question the
main question that I'm looking at in
this talk is a pretty basic one it's
your you know given a function and you'd
like to understand does there exist a
low degree so we're also given a
distribution D on RN and you'd like to
understand you know when there exists a
low degree polynomial P that
approximates F with respect to D
and I'll I'll describe the notion of
approximation in just a second but the
main application so there are lots of
reasons to study a question like this
but the typically the application that
I'm interested in is to learning boolean
functions and there are many scenarios
where it suffice us to prove a statement
like this in order to get an algorithm
for learning a class of functions F with
respect to this particular distribution
and you could ask well what do you mean
by learning a function if you're
familiar with the PAC model of learning
a function from random examples that's
fine we'll also talk about the agnostic
model of learning which is a model of
learning where it's like the PAC model
of learning but there's some adversarial
noise so let me just give an example of
so I should say that in this particular
talk just looking ahead a little bit
pretty much all previous work has kind
of looked at this problem with respect
to particular types of distributions for
example the uniform distribution on the
hypercube or if D is just a Gaussian on
RN typically their distributions that
induce some sort of product space and
what we were interested in doing was
figuring out a way to work for to come
up with polynomial approximator x' for
functions with respect to really broad
classes of distributions in particular
two distributions that aren't product
spaces and you know hopefully we'll see
some applications to like learning with
respect to law concave distributions so
one example which is lineal it's an O so
our nice on almost something like 25
years old so for example they prove that
if f is a circuit a boolean circuit of
size s
that's D then there exists a polynomial
P of degree roughly order log s over
epsilon to the D such that expectation
with respect to X drawn uniformly from
the hypercube of F minus P squared is
less than equal to Epsilon
so this paper I think it's the first one
that observed that if you can prove the
existence of these low degree polynomial
approximator x' for a class of boolean
circuits then you can get a learning
algorithm for this class of circuits so
there many things it's a great paper
than many things that were done in this
paper one is they sort of made this
connection between all anomie
approximation and learning
and there are two important technical
issues that they address in this paper
and one is you know how prove such a P
exists and then what's the algorithm or
finding be given random examples so the
algorithm for once you have this this
kind of structural statement about this
class of circuits the algorithm for
finding P P is what they prove is that
you know P is the Fourier polynomial and
the way you find this particular for a
polynomial if it's of degree D is you
estimate all of its Fourier coefficients
that are roughly n to the D of them the
way I like to rephrase it is that
they're basically a kind of they're
solving the following optimization
problem you're trying to find the
minimum over all polynomials P such that
the degree of P is at most D expectation
of F minus P weird and this is a so this
is a simple optimization problem to
approximately solve so maybe this is the
easier part of the paper but still
important and then proving that such a P
exists for this particular class of
circuits they use a method of random
restrictions and Hofstede's switching
lemma in order to prove that such a
polynomial exists okay so this is
so this is one example that I wanted to
talk about and then you know so after
you have this in a natural question to
ask is well I'm given some function
class F and some distribution you know
how do i they were able to prove such a
statement for boolean circuits how do I
kind of more generally prove that a
particular function class has one of
these polynomial approximator x' and a
useful tool another useful tool for
doing this was to examine the noise
stability of the function class so I'm
just giving some background here so in
2002 with O'Donnell answer video we
showed that if f is sufficiently noise
stable so if every function f if every
function in this class is sufficiently
noise stable then there exists a low
degree polynomial approximator for all
functions in the class and once it's a
simple observation and once you make
this observation then you can really
start to examine various function
classes and try and prove that they're
just noise stable and using this simple
observation you can prove that there's
um you can conclude that there's a
polynomial approximator for that
function class and therefore you can
learn that particular function class so
in this paper we are interested in
F was the class of half spaces and
actually more precisely intersections of
half spaces and there's been a you know
I guess over the last I would say ten
years they've been many papers I think
like Daniel K and himself has written
half a dozen papers along with many
co-authors kind of analyzing the noise
to bility of various function classes
over and then not just with respect to
particular to like the uniform
distribution on the cube also in
Gaussian space and really trying to
understand when a function class is no
stable and once you can prove that then
you kind of automatically get a learning
algorithm for free and so one sort of
last background note I wanted to make so
in in 2005 with kalaiy men's sore answer
video we showed that it suffice us to
have a polynomial approximator so it's
vices prove there exists a polynomial
approximator with respect to the one
norm the absolute value less than
epsilon for learning and so again this
is sort of a this is sort of a simple
observation you know one an additional
thing that we observed was that not only
do you get a PAC learning algorithm if
you can prove a polynomial approximator
of this form but you'll get an agnostic
it's implies an agnostic learning
algorithm and typically you know at
least in all the examples that I'm aware
of except for sort of what I'm going to
talk about today if you wanted to come
up with a polynomial approximator in the
one norm instead of a two norm you would
first prove the existence of a
polynomial approximator with respect to
the two norm and then conclude because
it that implies the existence of
polynomial approximated with respect to
the one norm so even though we knew that
you needed something weaker this kind of
weaker notes you know weaker notion of
approximation still all of these noise
stability techniques and kind of
distribution specific techniques that
I'm aware of end up first proving
something stronger and then just
concluding this weaker statement you
know if I have let me get through some
other things and then I'll and then I'll
define it now just because one time I
gave this talk and I got into this
digression about agnostic learning and
then like I ended up not giving the talk
so you know if you want to think about
it just it actually predates PAC
learning it's it's very interesting and
it's just think about it in terms of the
labels themselves are adversarially
corrupted so you get a random example
the label is adversarially corrupted
with some noise rate okay
for these noise yeah every well every
time that you're working that you're
proving a polynomial you know in this
metric in this norm you know and you're
working with respect to a product space
like I mean typically it's going to be
the Fourier polynomial so yes okay so
let's see yeah so what we wanted to do
was something so right so you know noise
stability I mean they're all in a way
you know Fourier based techniques they
all require the underlying distribution
to be a product space and we wanted to
do something for more interesting class
of distributions so instead of this
notion of noise stability we we're going
to look at something called moment
stability because if you recall the
definition of noise stability you know
it's the probability when you choose X
say over the hypercube and then you
choose Y which is a perturbed version of
X and you look at the probability that f
of X does not equal F of Y you know this
this definition or this notion of noise
stability doesn't really make sense
unless the distribution is product I
mean why are you flipping each bit
independently if the distribution is not
a product distribution this doesn't
really make sense so we're trying to
come up with you know we have something
called moment stability so let me define
it so in order to define moment
stability what it means for a function
to be moment stable I have to define so
we'll say distributions d1 and d2 are K
moment matching if for every
monomial of degree K X sometimes I'll
write just X bar to denote a monomial
and if I is an index set indicating so I
here will indicate like which power to
take which particular variable - I'll
write X sub I sometimes as a monomial
if so d1 and d2 are kamo matching it for
every monomial of degree K X bar the
expectation of d1 of X bar is equal to
the expectation of d2 of X bar it so
those are so d1 and d2 match all their
lower order moments and then we'll say
that F so f is K epsilon moments table
if for every distribution D prime such
that so I guess we should so fix the
distribution D so fix some original
distribution D then we'll say F is K
epsilon moment stable with respect to D
if for every distribution D prime such
that D Prime and D are K a moment
matching the expectation of F with
respect to D minus the expectation of F
with respect to D prime is less than
Epsilon so in words what this means is
that you you fix a distribution D you
have a function f you say that it's K
epsilon moment stable if it's
expectation doesn't change too much when
you kind of arbitrarily say 0 out or
truncate or
mess with the with the higher order
moments so if it's expectation is stable
as long you know as long as all of the
lower order moments match then we'll say
that F is k-epsilon moment stable all
right yes right so I you know you could
say F is k-epsilon moment stable with
respect to D yeah good so one easy right
so exactly so one easy thing to see and
that's leading into what I'm going to
say next is that if F is a degree K
polynomial then it's automatically
moment stable yes that's right yes I'm
gonna get into that yeah right so the
again sort of sort of easy observation
that I want to make that
if F so this is an absurd easy
observation well it's not totally easy
but I'll talk about it in a second so if
F is K epsilon moment stable with
respect to D then there exists a
polynomial of degree K such that
expectation of F minus P is less than
Epsilon in fact these statements are
equivalent so the proof is really LP
duality and then let me just say before
I get more into this I mean if you're
familiar with the notion of trying to
fool you know in pseudo randomness
you're interested in when K is
independent distributions can fool
various classes of boolean functions
that are defined on plus 1 minus 1 to
the N you know if you were to choose the
distribution D to be the uniform
distribution on the cube then these
notions exactly coincide of you know a
function instead of saying it's K
epsilon stable you could just say that
it's fooled by K wise independent
distributions but for distributions that
are not product this notion of being
fooled by a k wise independent
distribution doesn't make sense
because the original distribution wasn't
a product distribution in the first
place
so it seems like the right
generalization instead just instead of
saying you know you're fooled by K wise
independent distributions the right
generalization is to look at these
moments and to say that you know your
expectation doesn't change too much for
any distribution that kind of k moment
matches the original distribution and
this notion will make sense for any
distribution as long as the moments are
finite so it doesn't work for every
distribution but it makes sense for a
lot of distributions beyond you know
Gaussian Zoar product spaces so so just
very quickly so the proof you know let
me write down this
this linear program
so it's sort of it's a semi-infinite
linear program it's got a finite number
of constraints but it has an infinite
number of variables here you're
interested in this is like the
expectation of F the supreme over all
distributions new here you have a fixed
sequence of moments for every low degree
monomial these are going to be the
moments that come from the original
distribution D and this ensures that Miu
is a a distribution and if you look at
the dual of this program you get sorry
ya should be non-negative you're right
the enth
be the dual so you can see if f is K
epsilon moments stable then for any
distribution that I put here that
matches the lower order that matches the
first K moments this supremum is at most
the expectation of the original
distribution plus epsilon if you that
means that the infimum isn't most by
strut well so it turns out that strong
duality holds in this case it doesn't
hold in general for something infinite
linear programs but for technical
reasons in this setting it does hold and
here we have this is you can see there's
a polynomial here the sum of the the a
is of eyes are going to be your
coefficients and it's going to be an
upper sandwiching polynomial for f of X
and you know it's it's expectation is
going to be at most the original
expectation plus epsilon so this gives
you the upper bounding polynomial it
actually gives you sandwich in
polynomials but it's not important here
this will give you the upper polynomial
you can write another LP to get the
lower bounding polynomial but it's
basically a an application of strong
duality that that allows you to make
this particular observation okay any
questions on this in in this setting
where see these moments could be
arbitrary values and if they're totally
arbitrary then I can't say that this is
an if and only if but in the case where
these values come from a distribution
which is the case here you're always
going to prescribe these Sigma eyes to
be the moments of some fixed
distribution then yes it is an if and
only okay so this gives us
you don't get point wise you get you get
an expectation okay so this is sort of
the framework that I wanted to work in
and typically I guess I should say that
there you know for example in
pseudorandomness
you're typically interested in proving
that some class of functions is fooled
by Kay wise into independent
distributions and you start from the
fact that you have a polynomial
approximator here we're kind of going in
the opposite direction then we want to
prove the existence of a polynomial
approximator so we're going to try and
prove that F is a moment stable which
looks like a somewhat harder task and in
a way it is but this is the general
framework so I think one thing that's
interesting about it is that you know it
will not produce an l2 approximator will
not give the type of approximator x'
that sort of Fourier based or noise
stability based techniques had given in
the past this this it's an if and only
if for the case where the Sigma eyes
come from the moments of the
distribution okay right right you're
right yeah fair enough
if it has if it has if it has something
called sandwiching polynomials which is
slightly stronger than it will be moment
stable but strictly speaking you're
right now just the l1 approximator won't
get in yes well actually I thought about
that and that actually makes your life
easier in a way but let me get into it
later okay so let me just looking ahead
let me tell you that here are the type
of basically here are the two conditions
on distributions so here the two just
you know we're going to need something
about the distribution in order to prove
that certain functions or moments table
and so the distribution should satisfy
the following conditions first of all
every marginal it obey a tail bound by
that I mean so assume that assume that X
is assumed that the distribution is
isotropic and X is chosen from D then we
need that for all W of norm 1 the
probability that W inner product X is
greater than T is at most e to the minus
T so every marginal of this distribution
should obey some type of sub-exponential
tail bound and also the distribution
would be somewhat anti concentrated so
that means that
for all i if you look at X I the
probability that X I is in T plus e plus
alpha should be at most some function of
alpha ok so if the distribution
satisfies these two properties then you
know just looking ahead it's it's we're
going to be in good shape
and if you're familiar with law concave
distributions you know that it satisfies
both of these properties and that's sort
of why you know our main one of our main
applications proving approximator x'
with respect to law concave
distributions that's it falls into this
category yeah e to the minus T DS
exactly where it starts to break down
for that the moment start to grow too
fast ok so now that we have this
framework you know for example one
interesting case is you know let's say
that f is a half space and DS is some
distribution that satisfies these two
properties think of D as being yeah if
you're familiar with log concave how do
you how do you prove that you know a
certain function with respect to it's a
certain distribution is actually a
moment stable how do we quantitatively
actually prove bounds on this stability
so what I wanted to do is give you kind
of State State just a few theorems to
give you a feel for the what's involved
the techniques involved here they're
limit theorems and I should say that
although you know we had to find these
theorems in the literature and sort of
digest them and understand them and
they're so tarik on the other hand I
think that these questions are fairly
natural you know if you have to read
it's a natural question you have two
random variables there mo all their
lower order moments match you know
what's there see what's the CDF distance
to the levee distance between these two
random variables you know it's it's
certainly not as strange it seems like a
natural question to ask and so we
figured that someone must have studied
it and indeed it has been studied
so let me state a few technical theorems
for you I guess I need to define two
quantities which if you're familiar with
the problems from the classical method
of moments will look familiar
so I'm gonna define mu J of random
variable Y to be the supreme Momoa Alti
norm of T is one of the expectation of T
and Y raised to the J and then I'm going
to define beta K to be the sum from J
equals 1 to K of 1 over mu J of Y to the
1 halves it so if you're familiar with
like hamburgers moment problem what
there's a 1 over J missing I don't think
so I don't think so what oh yeah oh you
mean here yeah sorry so like if you're
familiar with hamburgers moment problems
you're given a sequence so it's just on
the real line you're given a sequence of
moments from some particular
distribution and you'd like to know does
the sequence of moments uniquely define
this particular distribution on the real
line it's an interesting problem and
there's something called Colman's
condition that will tell you when a
sequence of moments uniquely identifies
the distribution prescribed by these set
of moments on the real line and it
involves a quantity like this and it's
true when this particular type of
quantity diverges so it's it's not too
surprising that this shows up so let me
just state two theorems and a fact
theorem one just do two klebanov and
rack EV from 96 so let says that if you
have x and y there vector-valued random
variables so there an RN c so that for
all t in RN t x and t y have identical
UK moments
then the levy distance between x and y
is at most C times beta K to the minus
1/4 and 1 plus something it's not
important times Delta and I'll talk
about Delta in a second and we'll call
this alpha
identical to they have identical moments
of the first two k moments yes but
that's this is sort of a theorem that
gets you started yeah I'm going to talk
about that in a second
theorem to this is due to GABA vich
anyone plus a little we did a little
work here so pick and some epsilon in R
such that the probability that X is not
in this particular interval minus n sub
epsilon and sub epsilon is less than or
equal to alpha so this alpha these two
alphas are the the same here so you know
you're starting with kind of x and y
their first two identical two key
moments match you apply this theorem you
you get some bound here alpha I'm going
to mention what Delta I'm gonna talk
about Delta in a second but you get some
value here alpha and capital Delta and
then from this theorem to if you choose
this end sub epsilon so that this
probability is that most alpha then
Delta this quantity that I talked about
over here is at most roughly log of and
sub alpha
plus log of 1 over alpha raised to the M
so I'm not sure if that was very clear
but M here is x and y are vector-valued
random variables in RM no it does I'm
trying to simplify things it's a it's a
it's a major mess so you know maybe I
should if I if I made slides like I
would do everything in gory detail and
you could see it all but yeah oh the
levy distance between x and y it's a
measure it's a it's like if you're not
familiar with levy distance you can
think of
imagine you have the CDF of X and the
CDF of Y and you want to know kind of
what's the small like I wanna so I have
my CD f's and I want to know like what's
the smallest side of a box I need to
draw around X so that it covers the CDF
of Y so it's some kind of notion of CDF
distance of X&Y smoothness assumptions
in theorem 1 I mean I guess I would say
that like this capital Delta sort of
encapsulates a smoothness assumption
that you need to then apply theorem 2 in
order to get something to work yes
X not in that interval and then let me
just say so let me just say quickly fact
3 so theorem 1 kind of this requires a
tail the tail bounds from the marginals
this also requires tail bounds on the
marginals I'm just thinking about what
properties of the distribution we're
using here and then fact 3 we'll use
anti concentration
and it basically says so assume that X
and RM is a random variable such that
the probabilities of X I is in T T plus
is less than some constant times new
then this implies that the CDF distance
between x and y is less than or equal to
M times C times new I guess you know the
ticket weight since I want to get to
something else let me just say that you
know this this is sort of a very simple
fact
so you apply theorem 1 you get some
distance between x and y in terms of
leve distance it has this annoying as
you would say smoothing parameter and at
Delta you can apply theorem to to get a
bound on the smoothing parameter and
then you can move from leve distance to
CDF distance using this notion of anti
concentration and then sort of the
application we had in mind was so we
want to let D be a log concave
distribution and we wanted
to be the characteristic function of a
convex set so we were interested in
learning convex sets and in particular I
mean F could be any well any function of
K half-spaces in particular it could be
the intersection of K F spaces but you
know if you're interested in deep
learning and you would like to do some
function you know some type of neural
network architecture and you're
interested in functions of KF spaces
then this framework will also hold and
let me just tell you what happens when
you look at the case of an inter
intersection of K half-spaces
and the distribution D is log concave
you can apply these theorems in a not
too painful way to show that
let's see so let me do let me say it's
any function of M let me change from K
to n here so if F is any function of M
half-spaces
then F is K epsilon moment stable with
respect to a log concave distribution
and you have to choose K unfortunately
to be large it's X it's like doubly
exponential its X of log log n over
epsilon and over epsilon to the fourth
I can't even parse this myself but it's
basically it's it's slightly worse than
doubly exponential in the number of half
spaces that you're interested in and
epsilon and error parameter but I guess
I would say this is sort of a I guess I
should say that
so Daniel Caine also proved he didn't he
didn't use moment stability but he
proved that you could approximate
functions of half spaces with respect to
log concave distributions and his bounds
are only singly exponential I guess I
should say that you know before this
work it wasn't clear how to learn even
the intersection of two half spaces with
respect to log concave distributions
even in the noiseless model so
unfortunately the exponent when I say
it's a polynomial time algorithm I mean
the exponent is enormous but we're going
to choose M to be to an epsilon to be
some fixed constant right right
that's the point yeah the I guess the
point is the degree of the approximating
polynomial only depends on the number of
half spaces in the error parameter
epsilon so one so let me just mention
like one open problem so in this paper
we give a smooth we actually show that
you know we prove something more if you
work in the smooth analysis setting
where you get a random example and then
that example is perturbed the it's
location is perturbed a little bit by a
Gaussian we can prove that you can do
this entire framework in the smooth
analysis setting and you can get rid of
that the need for anti concentration so
you can do away with meeting D to the
anti concentrated if you work in the
smooth analysis setting and one nice
open problem is you know can you
agnostically learn a half space with
respect to all distributions in the
smooth setting for all if you want to do
it not in the smooth setting we know
that there I mean there many hardness
results but I don't know why it
shouldn't be possible to agnostic learn
a single half space with respect to all
distributions when the location of the
marg the marginal distribution has been
perturbed by some gaussian so that that
would be very interesting I mean one
problem of extending this particular
approach is if you wanted to learn a
half space with respect to like a heavy
tailed distribution where the moments
don't exist then of course you're going
to have difficulty applying this
framework but I think it's interesting
to look at these learning problems that
kind of seemed impossible or where we
have strong hardness results and maybe
think that the you know in the smooth
setting they're not that difficult for
single half-space no this one yeah then
it's easy it's easy to learn a 1/2 space
with no noise for every distribution
it's it's an easy application of linear
programming but the agnostic you know
when you want to learn it with respect
to noise if you then want to do it with
respect to all distributions it turns
out it's there many types of hard
initials there's cryptographic hardness
results there are many hardness results
but I don't know if these type of strong
hardness results when you work in this
smooth analysis setting so ok well do we
have time to take this question or am I
done right thank you guys
but then I start at 10:15 oh okay great
great ok so no I just don't want to go
overtime huh
ok so ok let me just say something about
the smooth setting I'll define it so ok
let me just mention I'll be quickly
define agnostic learning so yes yes ooh
much you can leave you can go
do you want to leave it I'm cool I'm
cool I'm not offended there's a seat
right up here you can get a better view
let me just answer for Gil what agnostic
learning is so you so just fix fix a
distribution beyond RN cross - 101 so
it's it's so it's an arbitrary joint
distribution and then you fix a function
class F and you define opt to be the
minimum over all F and F of the
probability when x and y is drawn from D
that f of X does not equal Y
so opt measures the air of the
best-fitting function in your class with
respect to an arbitrary joint
distribution on RN cross - 1 1 so PAC
learning the case when opt equals 0 so
when there actually is a function in the
class that properly labels every point
correctly but you can see that this is a
you know when opt is non 0 this is a
much more difficult problem and actually
this you know it's tricky as to who to
cite for the model of agnostic learning
I mean you could in some regard credit
vapnik in a way it predates PAC learning
because he had this notion I mean when
you find you know a machine learning
you're interested you have some
particular distribution you're
interested in finding a function that is
the risk minimizer this is the empirical
risk minimizer and that's what he had to
find I mean also David Haussler defined
a model pretty much to had this model
and then currents
Shapira and Celie are there also
typically credited for defining this
model but the VAT mechanic this model in
what so in some sense it precedes a PAC
learning so that's what so that's what
agnostic learning is you have to so you
have to find an H such that the air of H
with respect to D is it most opt plus
Epsilon so you need to find a hypothesis
you're given random examples from D you
need to find a hypothesis whose air is
at most the opt you know the air of the
best fitting function plus some
particular epsilon and really you want
you don't want to times opt here you
want you know 1 times up and you went
with in additive epsilon and then the
the smooth the so to answer Rocco's
question the smooth model is so if X is
the marginal distribution
then instead of receiving examples from
X you receive examples from X plus Z
where Z is a Gaussian and the variance
of Z in every direction is at most Sigma
times the variance of X in that
direction so you look at a gout so you
look at X you look at its covariance
matrix you know you have its covariance
matrix you consider a Gaussian with the
same covariance matrix but scaled sum
Sigma here less than 1 and you then
receive examples from the distribution X
plus Z from this new kind of Joint
Distribution explicitly Conewago you
know the well the you're getting
examples from just some Joint
Distribution and it has a marginal
distribution X and now I'm saying
instead of getting X comma Y you're
going to get X plus Z comma Y so yes
that goes and that goes into opt as well
right and then your running time is
allowed to depend on Sigma here and as
you can imagine if Sigma is getting
closer as Sigma gets closer and closer
to 1 the problem gets much much easier
because then the marginal distribution
looks more Gaussian and as Sigma is
small it becomes a harder question so in
this paper we give results for you know
functions of half spaces in the smooth
setting but you know and the dependence
is exponential on Sigma so we're really
interested in the case went against
Sigma it's a constant but it holds for
distributions instead of just being law
concave you can work with like sub
exponential or sub Gaussian densities
things that aren't you know modal you
can get around that
so supposed to came there's not a get e
to the minus T but C to the minus 3.9
it's something like that
now at the moment conditions won't hold
good but yeah just so taking all the
examples which are coming yeah that's a
good question we've like thought about
that and that'd be very interesting I
mean we can get anything to work but
yeah that's that's interesting oh yeah
then all of the bounds become
exponentially better you're getting a
stronger you have it you have a stronger
tail bound then you're working with oh
yeah I know we've tried to use these
facts about central limit theorems for
log concave densities and I can't get
them to really work in this scenario I
mean I consider these results to be sort
of proof of concept that you can do
something that we didn't know how to do
before and you know not have to work
with l2 approximator is or use Fourier
analysis but you know the bounds that we
get are sort of bad and I don't know how
to extend them yet so but conceptually I
don't think it's difficult you know as
to what's going on well everything
that's noise stable is also a moment
stable so that's good and you know of
course I would like to push it as far as
it can go but I don't you know I don't
know I mean we were happy to be able to
do you know convex sets and laud concave
distributions
oh yeah I should mention that Carl also
has a paper that's that he's going to
talk about that's also like about yeah
oh yeah what's your question sir yeah
where you you can't apply it so for
example KY is independent distributions
we can learn with respect to K why's
independent distributions we didn't how
to do that before and we also have some
alternate proofs for some other results
on the cube there in the paper for like
degree 2 PDFs
yeah it's a smooth analysis they're
their cue points but then they have to
be preserved I guess for the case of
degree 2 pts just regular a uniform on
the cube we can prove like we can give
an alternate proof of die chemical this
cane and Elson using this framework it's
a simpler proof but it's worse
parameters